she is one of the earliest serial
killers in recorded history the original
sadomasochistic femme fatale she stands
out as a shocking lesson interest and
dangerous a sadistic demented powerful
woman can be the passing of the
centuries has left us with an incomplete
picture of the true nature of her crimes
but what we do know is truly stomach
Channing in this week's biographic sweep
air into the depraved life of the blood
countess Elizabeth Bathory the woman we
know as Elizabeth báthory was born as a
shavette Bathory on August the 7th 1560
in near bateau in the kingdom of Hungary
she was born into one of the most
prominent families in Central Europe as
a result she was lavished with the very
best education in classical upbringing
during her formative years she learned
to speak Hungarian Slovak Greek Latin
and German Elizabeth was a child with
severe health problems historians have
speculated that the fact that her
parents were first cousins may have
contributed to her weak Constitution she
was an epileptic and as such was prone
to violent seizures it has been recorded
that young Elizabeth was exposed to all
sorts of horrific atrocities during her
formative years she is said to have
begun laughing at the sight of a man
whose crime was stealing being sewn into
the body of a horse she would also
regularly witness the severe beatings of
servants
unlike other young girls Elizabeth was
not offended by the violence that she
saw in fact she seemed to be drawn to it
by the age of 10 she had become a rather
stunningly beautiful young lady it was
then that she became engaged to a 15
year old Hungarian counts by the name of
faring canid a scheme as was the custom
she moved into her future husband's
parents palace and received education in
running the estate's that were under the
control of her mother-in-law
legend has it that Elizabeth had an
affair with a peasant boy in our early
teens and became pregnant it is said
that she gave the child away secretly
meanwhile Ference is supposed to have
discovered the affair had the peasant
castrated and then thrown to a pack of
wild dogs whether this story is true or
not it is clear that Elizabeth was
active sexually she married Firenze on
May the 8th 1574 when she was 14 the
wedding it was an extravagant affair
with four and a half thousand people in
attendance the party raged on for three
days at the height of which Ference
gifted his wife with a castle of her own
it just so happens to be Castle chesh
tits are one of the darkest most bleakly
gothic castles in all of Hungary the
castle situated in the little
Carpathians in modern-day Slovakia was
surrounded by a village and farmland it
would come to be the scene of many of
her most horrific crimes the marriage
United two powerful families and it made
them the power couple of the day for the
first few years Elizabeth was busy
learning about and overseeing the many
estates that she controlled her husband
was off fighting against the Ottomans he
proved to be a great warrior learning
himself the nickname of the Black Knight
of Hungary his absolute brutality in the
face of the enemy terrified his enemies
and shocked his allies the Turks invaded
Hungary in 1591 precipitating what had
become known as the long war which
lasted from 1593 to 1606 the war was to
drag on severely depleting the Hungarian
economy however Elizabeth báthory never
felt the pinch because her husband kept
showering her with gifts from the
ottoman empire in fact a couple grew so
wealthy that during this time they
actually lent money to the Hungarian
Habsburg Empire to keep the country
afloat during the war years cashed its
air was threatened by the Turks
Elizabeth had to defend her husband's
estates and she did so effectively at
times she also gave refuge to desperate
peasants feeding and housing them over
the first few years of their marriage
Elizabeth and Ference didn't spend much
time together when they did it said they
bonded over their love of violence
torturing young servant girls who were
under their charge Farren's taught his
teenage wife innovative methods of
torture such as rolling up pieces of
oiled paper placing it in between the
toes of a servant-girl
and then setting it on fire it is all
claimed that he gave Elizabeth a Claude
glove for her to scratch up the faces of
disobedient girls there is no doubt that
her husband introduced Elizabeth to all
manner of atrocity but there was another
evil influence in 1601 the household was
joined by a strange woman by the name of
Anna Davila it was rumored that she was
a witch
what is undeniable though is that
Elizabeth's personality underwent a
dramatic change from the time the Davila
entered the household she became much
more sadistic whereas her husband taught
her to torture Anna taught her to kill
[Music]
under the sinister tutelage of Anna
Elizabeth was responsible for the deaths
of several of her servants around this
time the disappearances of the girls
raised no eyebrows as peasants were
completely disposable at that time in
place any questions that were raised by
family members were squelched quickly by
virtue of the huge power that the
Bathory family had Elizabeth was in all
practical terms untouchable she could
torture and kill to her heart's delight
even the power of the family though you
could not prevent the rumours local
pastors became increasingly suspicious
as Elizabeth more frequently asked them
to come to the castle to perform funeral
rites for serving girls who knows
apparently died of cholera it is
recorded that one priest after having
attended too many funerals pulled her
aside and said to her your grace should
not have acted so because it offends the
Lord and we will be punished if we do
not complain to you and criticize your
grace and in order to find my words
aren't true we need only exhume the body
and you will find that the marks
identify the way in which death occurred
Elizabeth was outraged that the priests
would dare accuse her in this manner she
threatens that she had powerful
relatives who would not tolerate such
talk she then stormed out of the church
leaving it for her husband to smooth
things over with the priests together
the murderous couple had five known
children with the youngest being born in
around 1601 Elizabeth's husband farrance
became unwell we don't know the specific
nature of his condition but it led to
paralysis of the legs
he died in 1604 bringing their 29 year
marriage to an end at the time of
Osmonds day
Elizabeth was 44 years of age
the loss of her husband caused another
noticeable change in Elizabeth servant's
noticed that she became even more
sadistic the stress of having to take
the reins of an extensive Empire was no
doubt a contributing factor
it appears that she now transformed her
penchant for sadism from a hobby into a
full-time preoccupation specifically the
torture and murder of young women with
almost 400 serving girls over the length
of her vast domains Elizabeth had no
shortage of victims of course killing
her staff it was a bit of a hassle as he
meant that she had to replace them so
she increasingly began to lure girls
from the villages surrounding her
castles when she had had a fill of
torturing these unfortunates they would
be flung over the castle walls to be
ripped to pieces by wolves
[Music]
Elizabeth built up a loyal team of
sycophants who facilitated her murderous
actions Anna Davila was her main
accomplice also brought into the
sadistic circle was the nurse who looked
after the children women by the name of
a owner Jo there was also a friend of
hers involved by the name of door cap
there was also a washer woman by the
name of Katalin the most sinister of the
helpers were Anna and dorka who would
try to outdo each other in inflicting
pain on their victims the youngest of
the murderous clan was a disfigured team
by the name of Fitz Co the typical
progression of a servant girl into this
horror would begin with a simple mistake
in the performance of their duties this
could be as menial as missing a stitch
the countess if she was present would
fix an evil stare on the girl yell at
her and then begins slapping her around
Elizabeth had devised all manner of
creative punishments to go with specific
misdemeanors any girls who made a
mistake in any kind of sewing would be
stabbed repeatedly with long sewing
needles usually girls would be stripped
naked before they were tortured
Elizabeth reveled in inflicting
psychological torture on her victims
after sticking two needles into the
fingers of a girl she would comment if
it hurts the whore she can pull it out
the girl would naturally take this as
permission to pull the needle out but
when she did Elizabeth would pull out a
knife and cut the finger off she was
also known to have on at least one
occasion bitten a chunk of flesh from
the face of one of her victims servants
would be lucky to
away with a lost finger or two more
often than not the bloodlust within the
depraved heart of the countess was
unable to be quelled the girls would be
dragged off to a torture chamber where
Elisabeth employed her torture squad to
carry out much of her dirty work all
manner of implements were made you soft
cause the most gruesome afflictions
imaginable pincers were used to rip
flesh insides were torn out and there
have even been reports that cannibalism
was enforced on some of the girls we
know certain details of what took place
in the torture chambers of the Bathory
castles because of investigation and
trial transcripts that occurred when
face eventually caught up with Elizabeth
báthory and her accomplices however over
the centuries the legends took over and
many of the crimes attributed to her are
mere fiction perhaps the most pervasive
belief is that she had blood drained
from virgins and would bathe in it in
order to preserve her youthful beauty
this story is almost certainly untrue
not one of these servant girls who
testified against Bathory mentioned
anything to do with the practice rather
account after accounts mentions that the
floors of the torture chambers were
covered in blood which they would then
have to clean up the countess showed
absolutely no interest in preserving the
blood as part of some narcissistic
beauty regime by 1609 the rumors of what
were taking place at the bathroo castles
were rife but there was nothing the law
could do to put a stop to it
at that time peasants were unable to
bring charges against Nobles some
parents even looked at the demented
countess as the source of ready revenue
selling their children to her for a lump
sum on the face of it the trade was made
to provide servant duties but if the
child was to die of Cholera what of it
Elizabeth's appetite for blood was
insatiable the bodies were piling up at
such a rate that a group of enablers
were running out of places to bury them
many of the girls were placed in shallow
graves in the castle courtyards and some
of them were dug up by hungry dogs by
the beginning of 1609 Elizabeth's
closest confidante and a diwali died of
a stroke around this same time her debts
began to mount with all of the children
grown and married the countess fell into
a spiral of loneliness and depression
for some reason Elizabeth decided that
she needed to find a better class of
victim we don't really know why but the
general belief is that her lady steward
as the major Rover who
believed to be a witch convinced her
that if she took the lives of noble
girls her financial fortunes would turn
around or in they simply have mean that
she was running out of peasant victims
whatever the reason for the change led
Elizabeth to the decision to open a
finishing school for young noble women
it would be the perfect cover for her to
continue a torturous ways with a higher
class of victim at the same time the
attendance fees that the parents of the
girls paid would infuse some much-needed
funds into the Bathory coffers
by now it appeared that Elizabeth's
insatiable need to kill young girls had
led to the depths of insanity it
certainly clouded her reasoning it was
obvious that the aristocratic parents of
teenage girls who suddenly disappeared
would move heaven and earth to get to
the bottom of what had happened to their
pride and joy but none of that mattered
to Elizabeth all she saw was a ready
supply of nubile young bodies inevitably
the body-count began adding up and the
parents came calling Elizabeth made up
the bazzara STUV excuses one of the
girls had gone crazy and killed the
other girls before committing suicide
but no one was convinced some parents
appealed to the king Mathias the second
and he decided to undertake an
investigation the official royal
investigation was put into the hands of
the Kings highest ranking representative
Georg ethers oh this man happened to be
one of Elizabeth's dead husband's
closest associates on his deathbed
Francis even asked thurzo to look out
for his wife
however thursday's loyalty to the king
was stronger than that of his old friend
still he treated Elizabeth with a level
of respect that she would not have
otherwise have received though as I
began to interview witnesses he soon had
dozens of people who testified to the
countess's depraved ways servants who
had managed to get out of the castle
alive spoke of seeing blood drenched
walls hearing terrible screams and
noticing the ever-growing ready-made
cemetery in the castle courtyard however
none of the people that thurzo spoke to
was an actual eyewitness of the torture
thurzo he became convinced of
Elizabeth's skills however he felt
terrible about the pledge that he had
made to his dying friends that he would
look out for his widow he decided to
write to Elizabeth's relatives and ask
for advice a secret agreement was
reached by which they would be able to
complete his investigation but Elizabeth
would never be brought to trial she
would go directly to prison without the
embarrassment of the family that a
public trial would bring it's
interesting to note that none of
Bathory's relatives argued that she was
innocent by December of 1610 thurzo
believed that he had enough evidence to
arrest Elizabeth but he wanted to make
absolutely sure therefore he had himself
in the king invited to dine at Bathory
Castle Elizabeth was frantically nervous
but she tried to act the
gracious hostess things went well until
she served the men a post dinner dessert
a cake on thirst vice the men began to
feel unwell convinced that the countess
had tried to poison them they made a
speedy exit on New Year's Eve 1610
thurzo returned with a contingent of
armed guards they hid outside the castle
gates and waited before long Elizabeth
and her lady Stuart as he made you Rover
came out to cast a protective spell
designed to protect the countess and
bring about the death of investigators
Oh thurzo and his men listened to the
woman's incantations when the two went
inside the investigators crept towards
the castles entranceway they immediately
noticed the mutilated body of a young
girl near the doorway two more were
found just inside they then heard the
sounds of screaming which led them to
the torture chamber it was there that
they discovered Elizabeth's murder team
hard at work it is unclear whether
thurzo actually caught Elizabeth in the
act of torture however he was now
convinced of her guilt the countess was
found and taken to custody
she immediately claimed her innocence
blaming everything on her servants
thurzo wasn't moved however and he threw
Elizabeth into her own dungeon in the
end 306 people testified against
Elizabeth even the members of her murder
crew turned against Aaron criminais ting
themselves in the process the total
reported murder count varied between 80
and 650 Bathory's accomplices were put
on trial in January of 1611 scores of
witnesses and even some surviving
victims took to the witness stand the
judges also examined some of the
cadavers that had been taken from the
Bathory castles death sentences were
passed down to Iona Jo dorker and Fisk
Oh prior to their executions Iona Jo and
daughter were given their own form of
torture their fingers were torn out by
iron tongs before they were put to death
and then tossed on a bonfire visco was
spared this torture due to his youth
instead he was beheaded and then Burns
Catalan was the only one who was not put
to death she had been the most
soft-hearted of the bunch on several
occasions she herself had been beaten
for sneaking food in for the victims she
was sentenced to life imprisonment
[Music]
thurzo kept his word to Elizabeth and
she was never put on trial she was
convicted and sentenced to life
imprisonment in her own castle confined
to one of the dungeons which had been
the scene of some of her atrocities
early visitors were priests and the man
who had put her behind bars Thursday the
clerics reported that she was
unrepentant and crazed with rage none of
the priests was able to get her to
acknowledge the severity of her crimes
and she continued to insist that it was
her assistants who were the real
criminals when a priest challenged
terrorists why she didn't order them to
stop she said that she had been afraid
of them Elizabeth reserved the greatest
animosity for Thursday at one point when
he came to see her she began to subject
him to an awful harangue at which point
he interjected you are in the last
months of your life you do not deserve
to breathe the air on the earth or see
the light of the Lord you shall
disappear from this world and never
reappear in it again as the shadows
envelop you may you find time to repent
you'll be steel life Elizabeth báthory
complained to a guard that she had cold
hands on October the 21st 1614 he told
her to go lie down and try to get some
sleep
she did and she never woke up her body
was buried in the cemetery at rest it
said but it said that it didn't remain
there long due to local uproar at the
outrage of having such a murderess
buried in their midst the body was
supposedly exhumed and taken to the
Bathory family crypts however when the
crypt was opened in 1995 the corpse of
Hungary's most infamous murderess was
nowhere to be seen so I'm not gonna ask
if you enjoyed the video but I do hope
you found it interesting if you did
please do give us a thumbs up below and
don't forget to subscribe brand new
videos just like this every day of the
week and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]